all right we are back in Chinatown for a
mid-range phone battle
brand new Poco F5 Pro just announced we
got in our hands number one number two
the Samsung a54 tried to test it how
good is this phone though against
the Google pixel 7A in the house it is a
battle royale cool reign supreme let's
find out
we're now trying out the front-facing
camera on the Google pixel 7A 13
megapixel per photo and video let's get
into the video mode right here real
quick here 4K Ultra resolution that's
what I like not every Android phone does
4K
Google says we can do it let's rock and
roll we are now testing out the pixel 7A
here with 4K video on this 13 megapixel
sensor right now and it's looking really
good I'm in a bright light situation
right there there's uncle right there
we've got chestnuts darker situation
light behind me how is it exposing this
looks pretty good plus also the mic
sound how is it
let us know in the comment section below
now let's move on to the Samsung a54 now
we're trying out video here on the
Samsung a54 we are doing it in 4k once
again because Samsung and Google do 4K
how is the Poco going to handle it we're
going to find out anyway looking at the
exposure real quick here I can tell you
there's a lot more detail in my face how
it handles the backlight a little bit
it's pretty good pretty good exposure
these are really neck and neck I got to
give uh Google and Samsung credit on
this they both look really good but
Samsung I'm man I'm looking really
tired
it's like a really big contrasty and a
little bit over sharpened a little bit
so you may want to throw a beauty filter
on there I never would say that as a guy
but I think today may be the day I start
using Beauty filters on the Samsung a54
anyway now we're going to try out the
Poco F5 Pro now we're trying out the
Poco F5 Pro newly announced however Poco
nor xiaomi does 4k on the front-facing
camera even on the 13 Pro 13 Ultra we
don't even see it you're not gonna see
here on the Pokemon 5 Pro yes the xiaomi
makes smoke go points if it guess you
didn't know anyway look at the exposure
1080. it looks pretty good for the most
part I think not as much detail as the
Samsung or Google I'm pretty good with
backlight situation here well exposed
um it's looking not bad I mean honestly
speaking the 4K is going to give you a
little extra resolution
but I mean if you're using this for tick
tock or IG reels you'll get your quality
out of it but how's the mic sound on it
let us know in the comment section below
now we're doing front-facing camera
photos here with the Poco F5 Pro
a little HDR in the action how's the
image look not bad well exposed we're
gonna move on a little bit test it a
little bit more one more photo get my
durian guys right there well it's uh
that's it that's my guy front piece of
camera is okay it ain't gonna win any
awards but again this is the Poco F5 Pro
this is much more of a budget-friendly
phone anyway we're moving on to the
Samsung a54 for the front facing camera
when it comes to photos on this turn off
the beauty mode I'm turning off all
beauty mode man none of it turn off the
face stuff holy cow man it really adds a
lot of stuff but I guess for Samsung I
need that photo mode we got bird there
you know why I got some birds here see
if they want to take photo with me
the Samsung looks good we expect that
from Samsung what we see in their
Flagship cameras we're getting a little
bit of that right here in the a54
good skin tone rendering a little bit
more smoother even when you turn it off
but I'm okay with that but I gotta say
I'm very happy what do you think Zino
what do you think not bad right not bad
not bad I think we got ourselves a
winner here so far we haven't tried the
pixel we have not tried the pixel 7A yet
that could Trump them all or it could
fail let's find out front-facing camera
here boom
oh oh oh dude got a nice sight on
the front PC camera how about that a
little bit of night side action on this
bass reduction none let's turn off night
side just to be a little more fair to
the other contenders out there because
they just didn't have that love one more
for a little bit of backlight action
here next to my next to my friend
what's up friend a long time no see how
you doing a little bit darker in the
face man here is my thoughts thus far
with the front-facing camera when it
comes to video and for photos Samsung
and Google are really really close as we
already know 4k on both of those cameras
and again the resolution out of these
front facing cameras are fantastic the
Poco F5 Pro is lacking in that regard
but we're not done yet with this battle
I would say personally between the two I
may want to give it to Samsung just buy
a hair but it's a really close battle
anyway now we're gonna move on to the
rear cameras and see how they perform we
are doing video now with the rear camera
of the pixel 7A
look at this
4K
30p
we're going to see how the stabilization
is is I'm walking how the microphone how
it picks up my voice right here is this
the camera to get for the budget Range
phone I mean hey Google makes some
fantastic software for their cameras
does it hold up to their flagships
what do you guys think let me know in
the comment section below let's move on
to the Samsung a54 all right now we're
with the Samsung a54
4k30p uh again got some stabilization in
this is a really good camera system we
got to hand it to them even though it's
on a flagship camera Samsung has done a
really good job in their latest phone
offerings especially when it comes to
cameras hey guys how you doing I'm just
testing out some camera stuff here
anyway that's how we roll here we're in
Chinatown we're live we're rolling
there's Xeno right there recording me
look at look at that camera action right
there that's behind that's over the
shoulder action right there look at that
with the gimbal over the shoulder like a
g that's how he rolls like a G wagon
right there bam boom all right guys what
do you think of this video quality let
me know in the comment section below Now
we move on to the Poco F5 Pro
all right now we're looking at the video
here out of the Poco F5 Pro 4k30 once
again seeing how the audio sounds how
the video quality is now usually Poco
phones are better of course on the rear
cameras than they are on the front
that's how most smartphones are but how
does this perform how is the mic quality
out of this you know there's Xeno right
there once again camera over the
shoulder rocking it look at his backpack
right there it's called priest oh that's
my name and that's your name why you're
you priest are you a holy man yes he is
he's not holy at all trust me he's
bullish anyway let me know in the
comment section below if you like this
quality over the others
and then we are moving on to photography
now with the rear cameras okay so far
we've had ample light when it comes to
photos and video but what happens when
we go into an alleyway
this dark alleyway behind me how will
these cameras perform with their Knight
abilities
with low light let's go inside let's
find out Xeno are you scared
yeah let's do it man you can't say video
but yeah it's very very dark but that's
the whole concept so we're going to do
is try to find something like this right
here you see this got this kind of light
the shadowy area right here see how this
captures everything this is what the
Poco F5 Pro by the way okay night Mode's
pretty impressive you're seeing a lot of
detail pull out it's doing a good job
exposing especially in this lower light
situation gonna give it to the Poco
they've done a pretty good job with this
again budget friendly phone we're not
expecting Miracles here but it actually
looks good you're gonna see these images
as well without night mode and with
night mode Now we move on to the Samsung
a54 I expected things from the Samsung
phone I'm not biased I'm just calling it
like I see it okay night mode is
automatically turned on now on the Poco
you got to slide over to turn on the
night mode on this
is built in a little bit faster than the
Poco just like that has let's try
getting night mode on different lenses
not bad not bad I would say in the night
mode apartment these are really close
together guys I'd love to hear what you
guys think I would say the Samsung is a
little bit warmer in tone than the Poco
but now we're going to the king
of night photography the one that kind
of started it all the company that sort
of just made it go what you could do
that at low light Google pixel 7A all
right here we go I'll tell you right now
we know who the winner is
the pixel 7 8 it's most natural
doesn't expose as much as the Samsung or
the Poco F5 Pro for that matter but it's
natural looking doesn't look synthetic
yes there's HDR built into this yes it's
doing its processing but it's measured
out the scene really well so we're going
to show you all three of those images
right here with night photography you've
been seeing the images already let me
know your thoughts which one you like
I'm gonna give it though to the pixel 7A
for this battle anyway moving on there's
some more photography
in Chinatown once again anyway before we
get to the temple here's a quick message
from our sponsor if you're looking for a
laptop that has both power and
possibility look no further than the
Asus Zenbook 14x OLED it features a
large 70 watt hour battery and stunning
Nano H 14.5 inch 2.8 K 120 hertz OLED
display powered by the latest 13th gen
Intel Core I9 CPU and RTX 3050 GPU all
packed in a thin 16.9 mm chassis that
only weighs 1.5 kilograms so you can
stay focused at work or play for more
information check out asus.com
this is our guy
is our guy right here
he's part of the
[Music]
he's got his opinions on the phones
we want to hear your opinion anyway
let's move over here all right so we're
in front of the Hindu temple right now
and we're gonna take some photos of this
which is absolutely beautiful 64
megapixel sensor in this bad boy F 1.9
aperture I should be expecting some
really good low-light performance in
this of course AI is being kicked into
this bad boy we just got I have a lot of
faith in Google on this one love the
exposure ride out the bat on to touch
anything not Overexposed
hitting it on the telephoto on this wow
super wide wide nothing right home about
standard
is what we're loving it
the standard sensor 64 megapixel is
fantastic this is a really nice image
coming out of this camera system anyway
now I move over to the Samsung a54 to
see how it handles this compared to this
camera system this can be a tough battle
between the two I don't know how the
Poco is going to handle it we're going
to find out though we are at the
standard camera system
now already I'm seeing blown highlights
not happy close up on the two times
a little bit better
but on the one on the main camera
blowing out highlights
[Music]
go Ultra wide
blown out can't see it again
it's important little AI but see how
this pulls out a little AI action there
a little HDR too much nah pixel 7A all
day long and twice on Sunday if the Poco
surprises me
then I don't know what this review is
going to be like but if 7A is that good
I mean I'm sorry Poco I love your phones
but
I don't know if we got it here we're
gonna find out okay whoa
hello HDR you have a new friend
that's a lot of HDR right there that's a
lot of HDR look at that that is a lot
holy cow you know what just to make this
a little more I'm turning off at this
HDR I can't
I just can't do it
I turned the day off turned it off and
it's still
HDR
I mean non-hdr HDR no more difference I
think we know our winner pixel 7A done
all right I'll tell you what you know
you're gonna be the model yes give me
the model come over here come over here
come over here come on let's find a nice
light for you Xeno
you know
yeah this is good this is good this is a
nice got a nice little light here for
you okay
oh profile for Tinder say hi I like my
camera gear as you know let's go let's
go the a54 real quick
you give me blue steel you all got to
see this you're gonna see in the photos
he's like
the effect on this is strong decent cut
out bokeh balls look fantastic uh we can
change the background effect a little
bit allow it yeah we can bring down the
strength a bit down on this one natural
a54 is doing a really good job with
portrait mode xeno's looking pretty good
on this
looking good natural sometimes with
these uh these portrait modes you want
to bring the bouquet down I mean you're
not going to get as many you know bokeh
balls in the background it's not going
to be as blurred out but it actually
looks more natural than trying to go
super blurred out right let the
professional cameras do that phones
haven't reached that point just yet and
now
to our King of the battles thus far the
7A it already crops in a little bit more
the other options are more wider out so
I got to step back to make this more
interesting oh does a little bit of
relight you lose your earbud cable a bit
that's gone we got a little bit of
relight that's on that's on the on the
telephoto right between the two it's a
very close call between the Samsung and
the Google uh pixel 7A but this pixel 7A
out of camera looks a little bit more
natural but again it's a very close call
with either of these you're not going to
go wrong with it the Poco F5 Pro
it's okay
it's not going to win any awards but if
you need a Porsche mode in the pinch it
will look decent but just bring down
that background effect anyway that's it
for portrait mode all right Dino what do
you think thus far I think we have
ourselves a winner after this review
it's pretty clear I gotta say the pixel
7A for the most part has won most of the
challenges Samsung is very close in a
very close second with the a54. between
these two phones you really can't go
wrong with either of them now the Poco
F5 Pro
look
it's good for the budget and for the
value and that's poco's that's always
been their strength
but
against these two phones I couldn't
recommend it against this battle anyway
I want to take a picture of this Bible
quick Xeno I just want to just do
something a little bit different
I don't know man that looks really
natural I'm telling you the Samsung and
the Google pixel 7A are so close to each
other guys so close I mean minus the
color I mean this lime yellow green
maybe not my personal preference I mean
obviously if you have it you're never
gonna lose your phone because you're
always going to see it all right guys so
that's our battle right there the Google
pixel 7A is the champion the crowds are
going wild anyway the Samsung is so
close either one of these phones you're
gonna love with that guys like this
video subscribe to the channel we're
getting out of Alleyways right now it's
super dark we're gonna go home we're
gonna eat and we're gonna get ready for
that next video coming up very soon here
at geek culture we'll chat to you guys
soon you want to just handle this
you wanna just handled it
let's handle it all right
[Applause]